in this lesson we're going to talk about
complex numbers complex numbers is an
important concept to understand for the
s80 and so we're going to go through it
here so first of all what are complex
numbers well complex numbers are a
combination of real numbers plus
imaginary numbers and they're usually
written in this form a plus bi that's
called a standard form of a complex
number so for example if you had like
9-7 I the nine is the real part and this
7i is the imaginary part okay so I
represents the square root of negative
one and i squared is equal to negative
one so these two things you want to
memorize right here i equal square root
of negative one i squared equals
negative 1 so we were kind of simplify a
radical like this like a square root of
negative 16 see negative 16 is really
like square root of negative 1 times
square root of sixteen the square root
of negative one part that's I the square
root of sixteen we know that's four and
so if we write it with the integer first
this is going to be written as 4 I same
thing here square root of negative 25
that's like square root of 25 times
square root of negative one squared 25
is 5 and square root of negative 1 is I
so we would write that as 5i so that's
just a brief introduction to how
imaginary numbers work let's see if we
can go through some examples go ahead
and pause the video and do these
problems on your own and then we'll go
through the answers together so
basically what we're going to do here is
we're going to take these complex
numbers 3 plus 2i and 4-5 I and we're
going to add them subtract them multiply
them and divide them so definitely
important concept to understand see if
you can pause the video do these
problems on your own and we'll go
through them together okay so the first
one what you can do is you can think of
this as just like combining like terms
you've got three plus four which is
seven and you've got 2i plus negative 5i
is a negative 3i and that's it you got
it so it's into a plus bi form now over
here you're subtracting so you can say
3-4 is negative one and 2i minus
negative file I when you subtract a
negative it's like adding the opposite
so that's going to be like 2i plus 5i
which is plus 7 I ok now when you
multiply a little bit more challenging
hear what you want to do the foil method
or you can think about distributing
twice we could take the 2i and
distribute take the three and distribute
so let's go ahead and do that so 3 times
4 is 12 3 times negative 5 is negative
15 I 2i times four gives us a tie and 2i
times negative 5 is negative 10 I
squared remember I times I is I squared
just like x times X is x squared but we
know from up here i squared is negative
1 right so this is going to be negative
10 times negative 1 is actually positive
10 these you can treat just like like
terms you can combine them into negative
15 I plus 8 is negative 7 I bring down
the 12 12 plus 10 is 22-7 I notice I'm
writing the real number first and the
imaginary part second that's the a plus
bi form okay then the last one which
this could be a little more challenging
the dividing you don't want I in the
denominator that's considered improper
so what you want to do is you want to
get rid of the sign the bottom and you
do that by multiplying by what they call
the complex conjugate you change the
sign from negative to positive so what I
mean is you're going to x naught 4-5 I
but 4 plus 5 I okay whatever you do to
the denominator you want to do to the
numerator because this is really like 1
and 1 times this fraction won't change
the value of it it's just going to
change the way that it looks right so
let's go ahead and do that so what we
have is we've got 3 times 4 3 times 5 I
2i times for 2i times 5 I let's simplify
that numerator so 3 times 4 is 12 3
times 5 I gives us 15 I 2i times four
gives us a tie qi x 5 i gives us 10 i
squared okay 10 i squared and then in
the denominator we've got four times
four which is 16 we've got four times
five I which is 20 I we've got negative
5i times 4 which is negative 20 I so you
can see those are canceling once
positive one negative and negative 5i
times positive 5 is negative 25 i
squared remember I times I is I squared
okay now if we take the denominator i
squared is remember negative 1 times
25 that gives us a positive 25 right
plus the 16 so that means it's going to
be 41 and didn't honor so we got rid of
the item at a time where that was our
goal and then over here i squared is
negative 1 so that's negative 10 12 12
which is two and then plus the 23 I like
that now the final answer you can split
this up into two parts as they often do
and the right that says to over 41
that's the real part plus 23 over 41 I
that's the imaginary part and that's
your final answer so complex number is
definitely important concept to
understand for the f80 go ahead and
review the lesson if you need to and
i'll see you in the next lesson